foreign
[Music]
Billy you wrote a good song not a great
one did you guys want to record
something or fight more I'm fine either
way
okay let's get this uh started this is
Honeycomb
take one
can I ask you a question
what do you think the song's about what
do I think the song is about what this
is yeah what is this song what do I
think the song that I wrote is about
it's about starting a new life
[Music]
it's about dreaming of something
different
[Music]
don't stop
I wanted to take a daisy look we don't
need to argue
I was just gonna say that I love the
sound of your voice
[Music]
[Applause]
your first single and it hits number one
how do you stop that
[Music]
[Applause]
and you're making an album it's an
intimate thing it has to be I've never
seem to smile this much in his life
I used to be the first person that you
play things for
what people want to see it's an act you
know that
tell me that there's nothing going on
between us tell me if I'm crazy
[Music]
if you love her I don't well if you ever
do that is why this ends
[Music]
don't you think it's time to add a
little fire don't overthink it I'm the
fire
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]